today on our show man the Super Bowl
happened we did not [ __ ] watch it but
we watched every trailer all the ones
about Carl books
Charlie's trailer trailer that's what
this episode of fat man and Batman's all
about starting now
hello Oh true believers and welcome back
to another episode of fat man I'm Batman
I'm Kevin Smith from urban Hardin so hey
how are you I'm doing well sir the Super
Bowl happened I didn't watch it somebody
won the hectare if you'd imagined I'd be
into it - it's like dudes and colourful
costumes fighting each other it is
exactly like a Joel Schumacher did a
sporting event do you you know I should
be in if they got colorful costumes and
names masks
I should be all over the [ __ ] but I was
so bored they might have skates on
sometimes depending that's also called
hockey King we can't get into that we
don't have enough time to get into how
hostile hockey is on the show but when
the Super Bowl happens kids there are a
few moments for people like I so don't
give a [ __ ] about the pig iron and the
grid skin or whatever the [ __ ] it's
called they put up big fat commercials
and big fat movie trailers that's what
every movie theaters like zip so we got
to see some big fat movie dicks or tits
depending on how you look at that sort
of thing things are joy all all over the
place face neck and chest not the
trailer so we're gonna go over and man
that's what we're gonna talk about we
all watched it we're not gonna show you
the trailers go watch them online I'm
pretty sure they're sitting right next
to this like YouTube gives you
everything else you could what would you
do also everyone watching this show has
seen every one of these trailers already
nobody's gonna be surprised by any of
this [ __ ] but we got to do our bit man
we're gonna talk about put our stamp on
it
where do we begin Independence Day or
Batman let's begin with a dependence
I'll put my papers in this order all
right counselor
okay thank you thank you your honor
Independence Day resurgence had a very
explodey trailer mm happen much more
explodey than the last trailer that we
watched thoughts
I feel like this this movie is counting
on the fact and as most sequels do that
you have incredibly fond memories of the
movie 25 years old are you shooting this
year yes absolutely
it's there's a lot of nostalgia here but
I just don't know like I was there an
Independence Day
the war of 96 as we learned in this
trailer is what it's called I believe I
was there for what happened and it was
[ __ ] huge yes as big as a movie gets
in the summertime but it was a
one-and-done er you know what I'm saying
like there was no sequel Will Smith went
on two men embarked I believe that was
his next biggest movie star in the world
on the planet so like it was it was this
weird localized event of that summer
yeah like it was [ __ ] massive then
and then it was just God and nobody did
it anymore if you were going to do a
sequel you should have done one like you
know bad boys one a year and a half
later you know how boys to number one
he's absolutely right and number two
just like bad boys - if you're gonna
make a bad boys - you got to bring
everybody back from bad boys one I don't
know how you make this movie without
Will Smith like the Jeff Goldblum mojo
great long it's great and so Bill and
Bill Paxton Bill Pullman yeah is a
wonderful you know bearded old present
their back like whatever he's only
declaring to finish day again remember
me
I got another speech kids he's in it so
that he's there but like you know yeah
they got like a replacement black guy to
be Will Smith who is it I don't even
know just like a handsome black dude we
all remember that Will Smith was the
first one to greet the aliens mmm with a
punch in the face and saying welcome to
earth so it give you he's not back but
alright saying like throw the baby out
with the bathwater of course I'll
[ __ ] go see him things a lot of
exploding [ __ ] and honestly you know I
don't even know if I will necessarily go
see this like opening week it seems like
the kind of thing I would catch on like
cable or something like that yeah or
like you know a Tuesday matinee the we
could be yeah yeah or if somebody's like
you want to go seen a penny I got free
tickets above again Independence Day and
then jerk off oh my god I can have
everything just like those [ __ ]
aliens come to earth and one at all
as long as you booked in today with
masturbation whatever happens in the
middle everybody wins
excellent point or at the very least you
win life kids more you know with Jules
and live unless you know never to be on
NBC just masturbate twice a day be
honest with you like here when they
showed us here's the problem
yes when we saw in
penance Day 1996 I'm getting on my
soapbox when we saw a new Women's Day
back in the day and they blew up the
White House and they blew up like the
Lincoln Memorial they blew up every
famous icon on the planet that was new
like it was like holy [ __ ] is that what
that would look like that's [ __ ] up
then September 11th happened and we all
knew what real horror looked like and
then all the movies kind of adapted and
so even the Transformers had 9/11 as
images of buildings going down and [ __ ]
like Superman Man of Steel rather I
should say very explodey of buildings
and stuff like that so it just kind of
feels like it's a bit lost in time a
little you know I'm saying like it does
it makes me rethink whether I want to do
clerkes theory or not like am i if I do
clerks three of my Independence Day
resurgence where people like it's over
you fat [ __ ] move on who do you think
you are Jeff Goldblum like why why is it
okay or they are they what's gonna
happen predict the future and I'm not
[ __ ] on this movie I'm sure it'll be
fine but like there is an element of
like oh there was a window and you might
I just don't think there's enough like
[ __ ] boom like the way they kind of
play it they make you feel like oh [ __ ]
it might be huge I think it'll do
business let's be honest it'll make one
hundred million bucks but it's not gonna
be I don't think and I'm look don't I'm
no brought box-office Presta Gator but I
don't think it could ever repeat the
success of that first one and it can't
it can't repeat the cultural
significance of that first one did you
explain you know a single let him
explain I mean the first movie was a
Will Smith's like asserting his
dominance as a movie star you know which
he would do again and like help old
white dudes look cool became his thing
where Denzel went the other way making
young white dudes look cool oh my god
Tommy Lee Jones let's make you a
comedian because I have so much charisma
that'll just spill over and wash in your
face because you imagine although he was
funny you know as gerard in fugitive
yeah yes funny ish funny you know but
like you can't the special-effects we're
a cutting-edge at the time and at this
point we've seen everything that we're
ever going to see we slow up we saw a
star killer base yeah you
like what what how do you keep my on the
phone once they've seen a Starkiller
base we've seen a lot of [ __ ] blow up
kids yeah in fact in force awakens
Starkiller base blew up nine planets at
once making it real hard to blow up
anything in a movie ever get and have
people go like well that's impressive
yeah although I was like oh [ __ ] it was
like a pool shot there what keeping
pinky space
Destructo billiard yeah but like roland
emmerich like that's his thing what he
does is blow [ __ ] up real good yeah you
know did you know that he made a
Stonewall movie he did that nobody saw
yeah that is not what you want out of
roland emmerich yeah problems too
Stonewall for those that don't remember
history Stonewall is very important the
club in New York is a bar in New York
where the gay rights movement began in
earnest with bunch of people taking a
stand and saying no bunch of transgender
people a bunch of people of every race
in color
predominantly not white folks correct
somehow the movie became about how a
young gay white man yeah it's like find
me the one white guy Greenwich Village
in the 60s
it's like essentially telling like the
Malcolm X story but gone like let's
focus on his white friend it was just
the weirdest kind of way to which
Hollywood did quite a bit that's true so
he was actually right in the pocket I
mean you for historic lacquer remember
cry freedom yes that movie about Denzel
Washington is Steve Biko the early
apartheid like anti-apartheid rebels
it's about Kevin Kline yeah trying to
get out of South Africa it's like well
what about the black guy who's doing the
history he seems rather interesting no
no no a white priest that's what puts a
surface kids yeah it has been that way
for quite some time yeah so or so yes
I'm not sure exactly how many things
roland emmerich is going to explode in
Independence Day resurgence I'm banking
on quite a bit I'm gonna say a lot more
than he did in Stonewall you know more
shits gonna blow up in Independence Day
resurgence than did any Stonewall all
right so if you sat at Stonewall and
you're like [ __ ] rolling Emmerich you
sell out well I won't [ __ ] explode he's
back this is
you're gonna get now you win by the way
you get like you can probably check out
Stonewall in home video I'm sure I think
screaming at some point someone check it
out yeah but you really want it yeah and
you know what support my [ __ ] is like
I'm tired of blowing [ __ ] I've on tell
story it's important to me you went out
there and told them people like [ __ ] you
run right back to work man I feel you're
not good roland emmerich better alright
next up let's talk about another trailer
that yes I didn't see this one I didn't
watch the Superbowl so I don't watch any
of them on the Superbowl but I watched a
lot of them as soon as they I watched
Google News as soon as something
happened they were like this trailers up
so I watched it but I did not see the
new jungle book trailer did you I did
see the new how was it it's a it's an
action here there's no more so was
already singing yet did you see any
animal sing um heal did you hear Bill
Maria you hurt you hear Bill Murray
speak you don't hear him sing okay he
just whistles with the internet first
trailer yes bare necessities but this
time he actually talks
look at that shot he shot him with King
Louie oh my god that's so [ __ ] look
how impressive and massive that alright
they're selling the scale on this movie
for sure this movie was shot locally
right in a [ __ ] on a green screen
yeah yeah like everything across the
street or some [ __ ] like everything's
made up it's a [ __ ] Disney lot The
Jungle Book people like the live-action
Jungle Book this one is as cartoony yeah
it just looks better but everything is
unreal except for the boy right boys
real and everything else is yeah pretty
much in a motion capture volume hole is
that what they're calling it I can't
call it a motion picture anymore and now
this motion capture the volume is the
stage and they shooted it I see that's a
that's a fancy volume volumes turned and
just turned up to 11 to 11 on this book
yeah holy [ __ ] they did this cool thing
on the trophy I see that picture mmm
that water all fake isn't real or maybe
the water is real but it's just like a
green screen tub everything is [ __ ]
manufactured like that's crazy but I'm
with this and here's why I'll never
doubt this filmmaker in my life Jon
Favreau made honestly and I I'm not even
like the biggest Favreau flag waver I
like him but Iron Man is a perfect film
like I've watched that movie to death
dude I watched it stone [ __ ] not
stone
mostly stone up be honest today I watch
it when I wanted to watch it when I've
just been bored you could start that
movie anywhere it is perfection like
Empire Strikes Back it is an utterly
watchable film from from beginning to
left they should have given that do to
Star Wars but it's not too late they
probably working at Disney I'll probably
get excuse me let's start wars movie but
I would have given them like the next
one yeah not say anything as Ryan she
can't [ __ ] say anything but I would
have liked he's like Iron Man is such a
[ __ ] Star Wars Ian level good movie I
would have [ __ ] tapped him but so
I'll go see this even though I'm like
really man like come on anyone ever
complains about sequel and remakes and
this is about us secretly remake as it
gets holy [ __ ] but I trust that
filmmaker like number one he got Bill
Murray to play Balu that's pretty genius
but number two [ __ ] he always tries
to deliver man is a real he's a
filmmaker like true director at heart
good storyteller really good storyteller
man Iron Man is so [ __ ] impressive
dude I've been analyzing that movie for
years and I'm like there's no there's no
seam there's no you can't pull it
anything and watch it unravel that's and
you got to think about it that's
important because we live in the age of
the Marvel movie and that begins the age
of the Marvel movie not your Hulk or
anything like that or [ __ ] blade or
x-men or spider-man the age of the true
Marvel film as we know at Marvel movie
as we know it begins on the [ __ ] very
strong back and shoulders of Iron Man
like he's a God's [ __ ] talented yeah
we talked about like find me I'm getting
older [ __ ] you it's great you know like
dude we know he's good we know you're
bad he is he's really good so I'm not
the biggest like fan of like come on man
like I'm like I understand the business
we got to make money and [ __ ] but like
really The Jungle Book again but give it
to this dude and then I'm like Ryan
that's how you get my money you'd give
me someone interested yeah you know what
I'm saying like if it have been any
random dick bridge to presents the
Jungle Book
I don't know that I'd be gone but
because it's Favreau [ __ ] you Disney you
got my money I would like to see random
dick presents
now what did you think of this trailer
um I think besides action II here's the
thing that I that I kind of loved about
it and it's purely technical equipment
god you're single he's talking the the
trailer comes in TV laughs right every
now and again one of the beasts would
burst through the letterbox so you see
like the top of like Bagheera's head
over the letterbox thing and under like
the illusion of 3d sted built into a 2d
trailer that's kind of interesting you
know and so it does this very subtle
thing where it you do just a little bit
more invested the point is you haven't
seen that before
no that's the first time you've ever
seen somebody do that not your attention
so that money on the Super Bowl well
spent totally and they you figure they
were like we could just put up footage
or we can put this here his head through
the thing a little bit of a thing to
make you feel like this would be jumping
on it smart man now who makes that
decision
some people be like the filmmaker that's
a marketer yep there's new marketing you
ain't kidding or some team that Disney
hires I don't know if they do everything
in the house but yeah somebody some
marketers somewhere is the brainchild
behind that just like it I was those
Suicide Squad trailers I met the
marketing guy like he's brilliant dude
like it's so weird because you're like
how about we just give him bunch of
[ __ ] money let him make a movie cuz
he's so [ __ ] smart he's got
impeccable taste but those two trailers
from the Suicide Squad they're works of
art in and of themselves and that's a
dude that's just like you know he's part
of the process of course it's [ __ ]
higher up monkey monkey up the studio
but he's not making that film David Ayer
is but this guy's like I bet you I can
make a short film out of that film that
makes everybody excited and that's all
it is at this point I ain't just selling
the movie it's like this wonderful art
form where you get to make a short film
out of that material especially because
they don't have the entire film yet to
work with it's like yeah they're still
making a half of this [ __ ] is not in
post Lee and the effects are not done
yet here the 25 shots I've got to work
with and I got to make this thing with
almost nothing how'd they do the jungle
book trailer same thing cuz they done
when is that coming out some it's coming
out like me I want to say movies gonna
print [ __ ]
you know I'm sayin that's why it's like
you know some people be like what do you
fight if I'm fighting it but it's just
like in a world where people like we
want new
things this is not new no but it is
printing money
totally especially people what they want
and people even know they want this
until they saw [ __ ] footage of Bill
Murray the bear oh my god from you take
it all yeah it's like every grandparent
who's like they'll make movies I could
take my grandkids - hey look it's the
movie you loved when you also were 11
with the songs you loved when you were
lucky on fire they're killing it no I'm
saying like used to be when I was a kid
that's like you know [ __ ] the shaggy
now they're just like [ __ ] you Civil War
[ __ ] you Jungle Book let's talk about
Civil War man uh Civil War Captain
America civil war trailer was dropped on
the Superbowl how could you not you have
two teams facing each other this is a
great way to [ __ ] a short trailer
there so look a 30-second spot didn't
matter dude it gave us the line up
that's the important thing man
all right so there's [ __ ] what's this
[ __ ] yeah Winter Soldier oh that's the
new Ironman suit comes out his watch
okay so hold on this here's our lineup
they've finally revealed who's which
teams are listen Falcon off to the left
Falcons off to the left ant-man's next
to him okay Hawkeye cap Scarlet Witch
and Winter Soldier Winter Soldier and
now they're fighting for what we should
work for the government or [ __ ] the bear
fighting for to not register they're
fighting to keep their secret identity
look at our fancy new [ __ ] picture
get your graphics look at this we can
look at the picture and be in the
picture as well koala G all right so
wait they're the good guys they're all
good guys they're all good guys Democrat
cap was anti-registration
and I remain was Pro registration as the
Iron Man after sokovia is just like we
[ __ ] up right we have to be
accountable for our actions and they
should know who we are so we can pay for
our and Captain America who everybody
knows who he is it's like no no we
should be able to keep our secret
identities yes like you know what
I think he was just of the like you know
we're soldiers in a war you don't need
to know who the soldiers are you just
need to know they're fighting the war
and protecting yourself and protecting
the people you love is integral to you
fighting this war that should be a thing
you get to keep to yourself there we go
yeah [ __ ] will you just said there's
black panther man that's amazing
standing tall oh come on
so on the other side you got iron man
mm-hmm
iron Patriot or whatever the Gulf War
machine black widow vision
why is he teaming up with [ __ ] hey
where's Thor where's it's not in this
and Hulk is not in this either
that's right cuz you got those two
[ __ ] battles over whoever team there
they just punch each other [ __ ] boom
all right let's break this down dude
there I know there's a picture on the
internet where somebody like looking at
iron mans iron [ __ ] shoulder you see
that one reflection of a light mm-hmm
somebody online took it if you go deep
into his shoulder you see the reflection
of spider-man with a camera snapping a
big weight [ __ ] like really internet
internet tried to fool us all but in any
event run but they did raise a good
point which is like holy [ __ ] this ain't
all the heroes because spider-man still
missing and there could be some more as
well for all we know this is that one
fight scene in the movie man where
they're at the airport or some such [ __ ]
there he is dude [ __ ] king of Wakanda
and I love that everybody gets a red
head oh my god oh my god only one girl
for each team yeah pretty much we only
have two ladies in the Marvel Universe
and everybody gets one seems a lot more
alright but [ __ ] I ain't bitching
because that looks amazing
if every one of those characters punches
every one of those other characters in
the face you have my money
every line them up bap bap bap credits
nice that's all it needs to be that
looks fantastic so that trailers short
we've seen a lot of that stuff before
but those two lineup shots now we know
pretty the most juice if you will whose
side are you on I'm on the side of
justice
he looks amazing dude and it's just like
it's I can't again we say it a lot on
the show can't believe we live in a
world where he's in a movie yeah like
not just like aw we added him to the
Netflix show he's in a [ __ ] movie
right and he's getting his own [ __ ]
movie
what Conda is a word that your grandma's
gonna know well Conda that's where the
Black Panther come that's what she'll
say
what kind of pants are you wearing today
[ __ ]
judgey a little bit a little right when
you get to your 80s you get to be
judging you think you'll be that way
well no you lose bowel control but you
get judgement the trade-off maybe the
ideas we learned from that we don't be
that at 80 that is I gotta be this guy
the guy that's like oh my God my
Panthers in a movie you think at 80 I'll
be like I don't care I just don't want
to die I don't give a [ __ ] keep you
alive one more day
speaking of which we're beware young
vital men right now in our middle age
closer old and rocking the Reed Richards
you're a young vital man we're trying to
be young let's look at young things
while we're talking about trailers
Captain America a little little spinoff
did you see the coke commercial yes I
did coke commercial with ant-man and
Hulk was that Paul Rudd I think it was I
mean it wasn't they never show his face
yeah it was his voice though was it are
you telling me you know a thing that I
don't know I'm asking I watched that
commercial and I was like well I'm
sitting there going like you know they
didn't get a movie star no movie star
would ever sign on to do something as
gross as during the [ __ ] Super Bowl I
says to myself so I said is that Paul
Rudd I don't know and is it his voice
it'd be interesting to find out do you
think that Paul Rudd has a brother who
doubles phrase voice like Tom Hanks Jim
thanks
Yeah right phill rudd he's just like
Paul's busy today I'm fulfilled
Yoho give me a coke covert ads like he's
like when you get Phil you get Phil and
when you get Phil you get Andrew Dice
Clay Phil ok another x-men project my
friend or another Marvel project kind of
course ish is the x-men universe first
off I find it very surprising they
didn't use the Super Bowl to be like
Deadpool I know they're just sitting
there gone like this movies can make so
much money
ok go [ __ ] yourself it looks like he's
trying to make 70 to 80 million which is
opening weekend for a movie that your
mother she don't know Deadpool is it was
about to or is this never gonna go and
didn't have to go don't matter man this
movie's gonna make a lot of [ __ ]
money okay what are we looking at here
we're looking at so that of course is
Olivia Munn
I used to host what was it taking the
show to show me at one point back in the
LG force now she's [ __ ] psylocke and
I sat across Mar never once was over
like he look like psylocke but [ __ ] if
she don't look like psylocke she's
killing it all I got to do is put the
outfit on and have the body of course
and have those [ __ ] Ching ladies yes
she's my favorite character in the x-men
Sega Genesis game I love to be inside so
I'm happy to see this character come to
life
we saw yet another look at the x-men
apocalypse trailer mark are you excited
about this one I am excited and I will
be candid my wife didn't even know there
was another one coming mm-hmm because I
trying to insulate her from these things
yeah I like to talk about adult thing I
can't let this much nerd just seep out
in the house otherwise things will go
badly quickly you get it to me yes
she's like you give him all the best
parts of you how I give his beloved SEC
anyway and she was like ooh another
movie who's that I like this let's go
30-second chooses the [ __ ] really yeah
well there you go Fox well done yes you
got my wife to go did she see the
Independence Day trailer if she's she's
in the back for that really she is and
her Fox is for Fox
much she she's a huge fan in the first
movie really and so the minute that
first trailer came and it just had the
Jeff Pullman bill pulling Jeff Goldblum
and no woman it's a one mazing actor
votre Bowman they make really bold
choices but she just loves that speech
that is one of her favorite speeches
ever is the today I always thought that
he should have stopped it independence
mmm I know it's the title but
automatically speaking today we
celebrate our independence that's a way
to end right or you crop our cousin who
caused an intense day I mean really if
you're giving that speech it fired up
you're like today it stands today we
punch all the aliens in the face and say
welcome to earth that's what he said
right welcomes up he's like I did yeah
welcome to Earth Day what did you think
of x-men apocalypse yeah I know your
ladies in the bag now but she's in the
bag you know I it's still they're not
showing it's very much of it you know
they're being very seems like the
effects aren't done that's all yeah like
it doesn't seem like they're hiding
anything we're just like well it's still
a little bit early and I still like
finishing stuff up so they're not
showing us that much but I mean
forgetting yeah I did were seen Sarlacc
there's boys Cyclops and I would have
seen all the size you know baby storm
yes the babies growing look Archangel
angel and Archangel baby Nightcrawler
Jean Grae as you said man and it's the
girl from Game of Thrones
yes I'm Sam Sansa Stark there she is
look at her she's just like oh [ __ ] man
I hope so by fare better in this world
than I did in the other one last time
you saw me I was jumping off a building
with a [ __ ] the army what's a
Phoenix boy oh boy
man and there he is of course my goal
jobs Fassbender returning as Magneto now
he's played Magneto maybe about as many
times as in McKellen at this point you
think McKellen somebody do the man
because he's been more of them and he's
what past benders three
he's trying to beat him I'm gonna beat
him and son of a [ __ ] let me say I met
Ian McKellen once in a [ __ ] lobby of
a hotel it can one thing I can assure
you he McKellen does not waste his time
like to the [ __ ] Follis you ever read
any Ian McKellen stories no tell me it's
me McKellen stories just go look up Ian
McKellen online blog look up Ian
McKellen quiet life you're gonna find
anything
Ian McKellen parties do you like I mean
I know that's an old expression but he
parties and Harvey dude have a Wilding
dear boy you ain't kiddin Dave I can
hear the wizard for nothing he I was at
this hotel and cam and I was downstairs
in the lobby I was there for was there
for clerks 2 and X 3 was there so I'm
down in the lobby because that's where
the best Wi-Fi was and stuff early in
the morning trying to get online he
comes in and it's like 6:00 in the
morning and he was wearing a robe and
like nothing else and the person behind
the counter was like pop wah because
we're in France and stuff he [ __ ]
frustrated French he's that classy and
then he turned around and I was sitting
so I was typing and I heard the voice
and I was like is that the dude and he
fell get turned around at one point he
was just waiting for the dude and he was
good but the impression that I got was
like we were all our [ __ ] party
invention I lost my keys like he wasn't
hammered but he that dude lives I think
I didn't come out of my room now yeah
this is me coming back to my room after
the night bingo
in a robe maybe when he looked at me
like what are you you're on the internet
god bless you dear boy I'm gonna come a
thousand times in an hour
anyway x-men apocalypse dude one shot in
that trailer though that I do like is
when he pushes the one dude down and he
gets big big big kind of cool yeah I get
dude it's an experiment that's a branch
it doesn't matter it does them I don't
care who directs and I'm there for the
x-men support all these things yeah that
there's a shot look at that right there
yeah man I'm on board man I'm way on
board I'm Way more on board for the
newest x-men movie that's coming this
[ __ ] weekend man Deadpool Deadpool
we'll all be seeing it soon well I'll be
able to talk about I've heard from
people who've seen it amazing things
excellent we predicted excellence on the
show we did and this kid Tim Miller look
at that come on come on this kid Tim
Miller this heavy metals 50 years old
the world is oyster this boy this boy
directors crack the code of r-rated
comic book moves someone eiders like he
cracked the code what about 300 this is
fun this ain't like a sad scary movie I
said spot aware people yelling at each
other and dudes are hot and [ __ ]
oiled up this is one of them fun movies
where people like yeah yeah and then
stabbing a [ __ ] did you not find
oily dudes punching each other in the
face with swords not fun not a sword and
sandal kind of guy like I think it's a
masterful film it's incredibly well-made
I think he's a great filmmaker but like
I saw that movie once and I'd never need
to see it again and not like boy to
disappointed me I'm like lonely I get it
you're done it's beautiful to look yeah
but like some works of art your huh
appreciate you move on some [ __ ] you do
to death because you like that's my jam
300 not quite not you
I would watch and you know some people
that now I'm gonna lose all my [ __ ]
credibility on the internet when I say
this i watch Man of Steel again before
I'd watch 300 again I have watched Man
of Steel more times than I ever would
ever watch 300 but I probably watched
Dawn of the Dead most of all the Snyder
films okay
masterful you in there you know what I'm
saying like do you think about the level
of difficulty going into that job in
particular like you're not doing night
of living done you're doing the one
everybody [ __ ] knows and loves
yep dawn the dead they found a way to do
it crack the code that movie is
fantastic
utterly watchable you could put it
side-by-side with Romero's original
a completely different beast man but
holy [ __ ] valid in both of their own
presentations love and both that's why
that dude is [ __ ] successful and also
written by James Gunn was it really what
a pedigree on this [ __ ] movie did he
why do you wrote like Scooby so [ __ ]
smart this gun Kitty's going places too
I know somebody's gonna get from a movie
when you don't I'm saying all right man
so that's everything on this page let's
move to this page all right
they uh let's do the turtles next hey
Jimmy you gotta I mean if you know what
not for nothing dude bebop Rocksteady
and Krang the trying I mean they see
Jones they're trying they're throwing
everything in but the kitchen sink they
seem to have learned from the previous
stones and they're like we're gonna give
you everything you could possibly want a
turtle movie who's we're never making a
third one so here's everything that's
what it is it's got I mean no you know
what if there's not gonna be a drag
Vanilla Ice out of retirement not van
winkle crank I'm not a turtle's guy but
like I'm bored dude cuz they're smart
enough to bring in the classic
characters like that makes me
interesting you are far more on board
than I am don't get me wrong because I
saw that first movie in a theater yeah
give him a single I don't mean the
[ __ ] mean why did you go because my
son wanted to see us right you got kids
I got a kid of that age [ __ ] go the
movies we'll ride our bikes a movie
there'll be great did you ride your bike
yeah it's adorable
I mean we and we live like something out
of the peanuts we live near a North
Ridge which is where they shot et so we
can ride for these streets that kind of
feel like we're [ __ ] Elliot riding
through like we're having to chase oh my
god a bunch of adults stop you and point
walkie talkies uh-huh like chases with
fans and [ __ ] it's a little weird man
yes sweet all right it's away so I did
not like the first one I do not expect
like me and my boy had adventures on
bikes like et you know it [ __ ] in its
ass me and my boy Mike rode to see him
it sucked
did he like it yeah cuz he was like
eight four supposed to like [ __ ] at
eight they're not trying to get you as a
movie goer you were like oh as a simi
asked
I felt it fell a little short of the
mark really whatever [ __ ] mark they
said yeah [ __ ] working at it for you
little yellow bus bar like right here
I'm gonna give you a be honest with you
man the inclusion of Krang bebop and
rocksteady has put this movie on my
radar
okay enough that I'm like you know
looking at more true I didn't even look
at the trailers for that first one good
for you but this one I'm like let's see
look there he has been yeah my lord it's
like somebody trapped inside of Aegina
looking out at you I'm like Cronenberg
Ian this yeah did you imagine [ __ ]
David drunk if he did it [ __ ] Turtles
movie yeah he did the fly it's not like
I can't make a mainstream entertainment
[ __ ] that's how you get a hard dollar
yeah we don't want you do drama we want
the children Batman V Superman last
movie that made an appearance well it's
not true let's save that for the end
alright Jason Bourne dude [ __ ] yes yeah
it looks good right I will watch him
punch the movie like I just run again
Matt Damon punching people and running
away mm-hmm that's that's all me and
then just telling people he knows who he
is
yeah my name is Jason Bourne I'm not
even trying anymore with the title now
they're just calm Jersey one look at him
dude look how tough he looks good will
hunting hunting your [ __ ] ass blowing
your [ __ ] face off I am the man who
knocks you want to break it bad you dick
and he's like oh then I don't know why
I'm sorry I was just
improving on that she would read it look
at this man apparently a scene takes
place and in Batman Begins
her on the air Fiat greatest that dude
he's got the gun show and Tim really
does a Martian like he played a math kid
in the Martian in this movies like but
he was still a Matthew with gonna burn
he's playing Bane in this movie so
[ __ ] bored he left the franchise when
nine years ago almost a decade later the
man has returned with Paul Greengrass
the director yep if you like born it
looks he looks born again there I said
hey I don't know why they didn't use
that time know what I'm saying so
obvious I guess and born is born again
born again just call it born again I
guess the the again would infer like
born again the Martian punching people
again you could mark it as Martian too
he's back on earth and he's mad he's
punching [ __ ] in the face I was in
space I had to use my own pee and poo
the [ __ ] out of your head alright man
last trailer that's not Batman V
Superman related 10 Cloverfield Lane
can't [ __ ] wait Yeah right come on
dude John Goodman I love John Goodman
this trailer throw up an image of some
sort show them what it looks like it is
we ain't got none [ __ ] it Oh God for you
imagine oh it all looks like it takes
place in like a missile like a bunker
bunker like a nuclear shelter nuclear
fallout shelter which is so smart
yeah you know in something like how
cheap is that let me save your facts for
like [ __ ] five scenes and you're out
and also that's the way you shoot a
movie and nobody knows you're shooting a
movie if everything is in like one
secure location nobody's walking in and
out of any place there's no like it's
like where this movie come from that's
where this movie came from yeah every
year [ __ ] like JJ's the master of
sleight of hand you're looking at
[ __ ] force awakens they're over there
quietly making 10 Cloverfield Lane he's
not the director but he's the producer
it's a bad robot movie and obviously as
we hear at the end of this spa
like [ __ ] monsters man [ __ ] yes can't
wait and this one's like a freebie
I know we have to pay to see it but like
we weren't expecting this it's kind of
like Banas i do i do wish that at some
point somebody manages a crack thee I
shot a movie and you know what tomorrow
you can go see it like Lyra they do the
distribution they do that in theaters
they figure out a way to be like Beyonce
with an album with a movie I'd like to
do that I mean I don't know how I don't
know how you I make movies that go
theaters fast leave the theaters but
yeah that'd be amazing run movie run
that's I mean you could do that people
do it online and [ __ ] but to do with a
major motion picture like we finished
this [ __ ] for hide a like watch it
Friday night there's three thousand
screams oh my god no promotion no
advertising we just drop in a movie
marketing right here higher mark barnard
yes - somehow [ __ ] with your movie and
everybody's coming out not the greatest
Morgan I got interesting $8 this weekend
nobody knew both the show is titled fat
man I'm Batman so we should mention the
new Gotham there's a new trailer for
Gotham ladies and gentlemen that
features both Hugo Strange man doctor
mr. freeze doctor freeze what a dick i
mr. freeze i buyed that he's a doctor
though and he is though he's dr. Vicktor
bomb for you yeah so he could be doctor
freeze why not give that due to
promotion I don't even think he's Victor
Von I think I threw the Vaughn and I'm
confusing with Victor Von Doom just
about Victor freeze yeah but he is a
doctor yeah okay B dr. freeze it should
be doctor free yeah it's not a mystery
Detroit and dr. Detroit no medical I see
he had no post-grad well
epic metal Kalon [ __ ] I thought you were
to throw up a picture dr. Troy oh my god
is a brilliant [ __ ] poem nice job man
that of course is what he wants bTW Wong
man from Jurassic Park the guy without
whom there is no Jurassic Park movies
guy that made the eggs and [ __ ] he's in
Jurassic world and he's a Jurassic world
he's [ __ ] up all over the place and
now he's playing dr. Hugo Strange in
Gotham so if I don't have to get you to
watch Gotham you know I want you when
they're done with this season you know
yeah yeah well they put a lot of [ __ ]
seems that they did this season what
they should have done last season which
is just like using a bunch of villains
never mind ones you didn't hear of like
fish Mooney here's a bunch of fellas
you've heard of we have the best rogues
gallery in comics let's do them feels
like they just realized it this season
hopefully it's not too little too late
okay finally folks the Super Bowl meant
we got to see a bizarre little piece of
marketing most people chose to show new
footage from a movie or old footage with
a new shot or actual trailers full blown
trailer Batman the Superman took this
different approach in partnership with
Turkish Airlines good cos sure we've all
flown them like the Southwest of the
Midwest Turkish Airlines Turkish
Airlines I guess is a partner on the
movie there you see one of the fine
Turkish airline flights
that's a jet that is a jet flying over a
fiction we believe there are two spots
that they ran one for visit metropolis
and one for a visit Gotham and in the
metropolis one Lex Luthor right so they
showed Jesse Eisenberg if shots the
Daily Planet building they showed Jesse
Eisenberg as Lex Luthor in character and
I'm in a jet in a commercial spot though
yeah the Superbowl
look there is three lines he's on the
plane
stewardess oh yeah mr. Luthor can shots
Otis this time around sexy very
interesting approach sure but if you're
gonna do metropolis you have to do
Gotham true so that led to this do we
have any images of this
yeah so they say we announce you know an
opening of flights to compensating for
the first time yeah nobody's ever flown
there before all the fires are out first
view of ace chemicals dude which
apparently is in the [ __ ] middle of
the city is that really a place for a
chemical plant probably not and look at
look at looky-looky-looky showing four
Turkish Airlines
it's Bruce Wayne CEO wave enterprises as
one of our first looks outside of a
trailer Ben Affleck playing the
inimitable Bruce Wayne CEO of Wayne
Enterprises there's another shot that
almost looks like that one poster for
the Dark Knight Returns and there's a
goal and they say in the spot that like
if you're lucky you might see your local
Zoo Liberty and they put up the bat
signal and stuff so you know it's weird
and then they end with him on a Turkish
Airlines flight that's the look I want
out of my Bruce Wayne you like so no
that one was I mean look you know like
they're a partner and they're spending a
but you know who spent the money on
those Super Bowl ads turkeys you're
lying
exactly that's why you do something like
that Warner Brothers did enough to put
out to five million dollars whatever
[ __ ] it cost this year Turkish Airlines
did it so I guess it's a smart pairing
up interesting yeah it's weird though
odd it is very weird because they kind
of backdoored two famous people into
doing big commercials which to be fair
those commercials were on the Super Bowl
maybe there's some sort of likes only
playing once on the Super Bowl won't be
played on TV again after this or it's
only be online spots or something like
that but it's a it's interesting it has
the feel of a thing that was supposed to
be viral that they didn't trust to go
viral
you know like it should have been the
thing that oh look what I [ __ ] found
this weird thing that they shut is
buried in a web site it's a bad with
Bruce Wayne and said it's we spent two
million dollars to show you 30 seconds
in this commercial
yeah which is a little okay or maybe
they were like we had a spot that we
want to go with but like we just showed
a spot with doomsday maybe we don't want
to show another spot but I don't know
it's like February and this thing opens
March 25th that's like a month and
change so it was a it was a weird
decision not a bad one and it also is an
insight into the movie and stuff it's
just very untraditional yeah
by now we
this stage is when you hit them hard my
choice I mean I would number one I would
had a Suicide Squad commercial on the
same one that they did I would in a
30-second spot got that on there but
yeah I would have went a little more
like hey therefore a little less meta
and a little more Mita in any event
though its original in a world where we
all want originality those two spots are
very original so hats off for the
originality man hats off to all the fine
marketers behind all these spots because
let's be honest I know we're supposed to
credit the filmmakers but the true
filmmakers in these spots are not the
people of mayhem you know people that
took that movie and turned it into like
30 seconds of like I must see it
they sold mark Bernardin's wife an x-men
movie which let's not kid ourselves is a
huge [ __ ] sell somebody at Fox
deserves a [ __ ] raise here take this
to your boss guy made [ __ ] we're
gonna have fun saying yeah Phil Roger
[ __ ] totally run with an envelope
showing up at your house buddy Billy
Rudd is you don't [ __ ] around Philly
ruff what do you need that's all the
news we got pretty much me thanks for
hanging out and watching us read other
people's news man most of this is
sourced from comicbook.com Comic Book
Resources a bunch of fine websites and
whatnot without them we have no show we
certainly don't have a show without our
producer Matt steals all the news from
the website yes
highway robbery Phil thank you hey man
we're not delivering breaking news this
is just us filter in the news for you
massaging it yeah we're just making a
course and then giving it back to you
makes a little easier to take when it
comes from us pretty much
non-threatening dudes with little dicks
and boobs
that's the original title for the show
but it's dead fat Mountain Batman Ryan
so we went with that c4 fat man I'm
Batman I'm Kevin Smith mark barnard mark
boobs burn Arden as we call him come
back see us in the fact cave in a couple
days men saying fat time saying fat
channel youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Music]
hey Nance me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder